did you serve I did where where did you
start Maureen me too what was your MOS I
was special oh I see okay
I flew into places okay where were you
dark places where were you stationed I I
uh can't go into detail okay okay but
this interview is over it's all super
super secret now again MOS just means
military occupational specialty it's
just a super General role were you in
personnel and administration were you in
logistics the guy could have just said I
was in intelligence I was in avionics I
was whatever it's really tough to tell
whether it's completely made up but
again current Marines wrote to me and
said David this stuff stinks to high
heaven this guy is just straight up
making it up if he did serve and he's
just wacky right now because he's you
know infected with the Trump virus fine
but uh many members of the military in
our audience
extraordinarily skeptical about this
guy's story